es una conferencia de paz en un momento
de creciente inestabilidad
iniciada por Francia ir a casi un año
Bagdad 2 que se celebra en Jordania
pretende devolver la estabilidad a Irak
y también a la región la región sigue
enfrentando a bloqueos divisiones
injerencias extranjeras problemas de
seguridad e Irak es probablemente dada
las últimas décadas una de las
principales Víctimas de la
desestabilización regional algo
demasiado ambicioso dicen algunos
observadores dado sus recientes
acontecimientos en el medio oriente
durante tres meses las protestas por
maxa amini se han extendido por Irán
reprimidas violentamente por el régimen
Siria sigue siendo escenario de
enfrentamientos entre potencias
extranjeras mientras que Irak acaba de
nombrar Primer Ministro a un político
proirán y tras un año de crisis política
para Teherán la Cumbre es una
oportunidad de volver a poner sobre la
mesa su programa nuclear suspendido tras
las sanciones impuestas por Estados
Unidos Hace 4 años
Jordania es una buena oportunidad para
concluir estas conversaciones Espero que
veamos un cambio de rumbo por parte de
los estadounidenses y que Estados Unidos
se comporte de forma más realista uno de
los principales observadores es el
responsable de la política exterior de
la Unión Europea josephell que
coordinará las conversaciones el
objetivo es garantizar que la política
nuclear iraní siga siendo solo para uso
civil a cambio de una relajación de las
sanciones para ellos será necesario el
acuerdo de Arabia saudí principal rival
Regional de Irán pero con toda una serie
de influencias en juego en toda la
región conseguir cualquier acuerdo en
esta conferencia será probablemente una
ardua tarea